look just on the last seven years about
somewhere around two and a half million
dollars worth of cars and I can tell you
from experience I've made all the
mistakes and the worst thing about
buying the cars of frustration that
comes after you're going to a dealership
and the reason why I say that is because
typically when people buy a car the
mistake they make is they go to a
dealership first and that's not what you
want to do first here's what I recommend
the first thing you ought to do is call
an online auto broker here's why they
have inventory of every single car in
America let me explain I wanted to buy a
dawn I was looking for Salamanca blue
dawn that's the only one I was
interested in I called him
Danny Danny looked up in his inventory
came back and told me there's one in
Naples Florida for sale right now I said
great I call Naples dealership myself
they told me four hundred and six
thousand dollars he calls the dealership
he got three hundred and eighty eight
thousand dollars three days later that
car was delivered to my house I never
had to talk to the sales guys to
negotiate nothing he did it for me car
came to me delivered I signed a piece of
paper thirty second boom the guy was
gone right so number one they have
inventory number two time I don't have
to sit on a dealership for hours and say
oh my gosh I went to the first one then
the second one then the third one by
this time I'm so burned out I'll say yes
to anything because I just want to go
home and watch football spend time with
the kids and relax I don't have any time
to be around these dealer guys they're
annoying they're pushing me away too
much hypothetically that's what a lot of
people say so time third one money why
do you save money these online auto
brokers have corporate fleet licenses
which means they get a discount on the
cars because they buy a certain amount
of dollars of cars every year so they
get a discount you and I don't get
because of that pool of discount that
they get you get to participate in it so
they'll call the dealership and they'll
say my customers willing to buy this car
for this price and the payment needs to
be $1,200 they'll pretty much negotiate
and the dealership will say now we're
not gonna hit it because they contact so
many different dealerships somebody says
yes then I'm because Taney Taylor quota
they haven't sold anything they're
sitting on some cars that they got to
get rid of and you get the discount for
that because the broker the consultant
does the selling for you now you you
simply tell the consultant price point
what you're looking for he makes the
phone call look some of you may have
already said in commented belong said
hat you shouldn't go deal with an online
auto broker their apps to buy cars let
me explain to you why I'm not a fan of
apps when it comes onto buying cars
here's why as a financial advisor I can
use each trade and go buy stocks and
then lose money because I'm not the
expert or I can use an expert that
Bessus for living and they counsel me on
what to look for what not to look out
for because that's what they do 24/7 you
see when you deal with an online auto
broker they know which cars are running
discounts which cars are not I'll give
you an idea I called one of my guys
named Barrett here's what he said
we were about to buy an e 350 he says
Patrick mercedes-benz has a reputation
I'm changing the e-class every eight
years
it's your seven you're gonna buy it a
year from now it's gonna look like an
old Mercedes as if it wasn't a three I
don't recommend you buying it I said why
that makes a lot of sense now adjust and
look at 750 because 750 just came out
and they're gonna be on the marketplace
and this cost us this much that ones is
this much and then he gave me a couple
other options but that advice I'm not
gonna get from the app that advice I'm
gonna get from somebody on Dilma as a
consultant and then they tell me just so
you know right now Lexus is running
specials
you know BMW is not Mercedes is not all
they'll say things like Nissan had some
issues with this car they had a big
thing that just happened with them I
wouldn't buy their car right now or
these guys are running specials on you
know financing for least this one which
your credit I can use this guy with this
do you have access to that but they're
gonna know all the specials on different
kind of cars that's taking place so in
essence they're playing the role of an
adviser to you